there are clearly many mistakes made at
the RNC but I'd like to mention just one
more regarding Donald Trump's choice of
song for his entrance on Monday night
yes that is Queen being played at the
Republican National Convention so it's
with a heavy heart that I announce
Freddie Mercury dead again at age 69 now
now Queen didn't give Trump permission
to use that song tweeting it was an
unauthorized use at the Republican
convention against our wishes and yet on
his closing night Trump used another
unauthorized song to cover him dropping
what was an almost sarcastic amount of
balloons and you will never guess what
song it was no look Trump has used
unauthorized music throughout his
campaign and if you think you can't
always get what you want was a bit on
the nose just wait until you hear what
song he used ahead of a speech he gave
on the Iran nuclear deal and just so you
know this is real we did not alter the
audio at all businessman Donald Trump
I mean that is just too perfect Chung
may as well have been riding out on
stage with the three other Horsemen of
the Apocalypse and to be fair it is by
no means just Trump who is angered
musicians by using their music without
permission Mike Huckabee pissed-off
survivor by using eye of the tiger and
Scott Walker had this happen after
wisconsin Governor Scott Walker used
music from the Dropkick Murphys
they tweeted it to him we literally hate
you look we got that they may be angry
Boston hooligans but I'll say this about
the Dropkick Murphys they know when to
properly use the word literally none of
this is anything new politicians have
been appropriating pop music for as long
as anyone can remember
over the years Sarah Palin has gotten in
trouble for using Hart's Barracuda John
McCain was asked to stop using to John
Mellencamp songs at the DNC was
criticized by Cyndi Lauper for using
true colors and perhaps most famously
three decades ago there was this Ronald
Reagan used the song born in the USA in
1984 for his reelection campaign until
Springsteen suggested maybe he should
listen to the lyrics Springsteen
actually penned the tune about the dark
side of the American story and the harsh
treatment of Vietnam veterans now to be
fair to Reagan most people don't realize
that I always assumed that like every
other Springsteen song it was about
struggling midnight heroes and their
barefoot lovers all named Mary who broke
free of that one-horsepower town on
bikes chased by shadows but the point is
the point here is if artists want to
lend their music to politicians that's
fine but it is not okay for politicians
to just take their songs
this happens every single election and
it is time for musicians to come
together and take a stand
it's that time
you campaign season see you you're
waving point make your speeches while
balloons fall everywhere but we notice
something's wrong and it's gone on way
too long so we're asking you right now
stop using a song
laser lightshow
fire up you can Fetty machine bring out
your smiling backdrop up ethnically
diverse teams music we do
just can't face
you using wrong
if I seem appealing
but you're just stealing
don't you dust
it just seems wrong
we don't sue don't use a song
that's Licensing's you gotta call my
publisher okay
you always take a music out of context
why would ray in the plane
born in the USA it's about Vietnam
that's
you did
if I wanted to sing cannot get paid I'd
be on Spotify
six
you're so
you're lucky we don't sue
and what's the deal with all those
balloons
you can't use the song
you
come on don't you use it to deal with
all
the Georgia
but you didn't
you know
you